recently you may have heard that russia
may be loosening restrictions on piracy
in an effort to combat all the tech
sanctions that have been placed on their
citizens this makes sense as basically
every tech and media company you can
think of has sanctioned russia so in
order to continue being productive and
to get some entertainment russia
basically has to turn to piracy but
something that you may not have expected
though is that there are rumors and
speculation floating around that biden
may not only lose restrictions
surrounding piracy
but he may legalize piracy altogether in
america with an upcoming executive order
ever since these rumors surfaced pirates
from around the world have rejoiced as
this move could spark an international
copyright revolution in the meantime
production studios have been mortified
as they struggle to understand how the
billions they spent on lobbying failed
to prevent this so here's the reasoning
behind why biden may be introducing this
legislation the details about what it
may include and its potential short and
long term repercussions
starting with the reasoning for such a
move we have the deflation crisis as you
guys know over the past year deflation
has gone through the roof
now this may be confusing at first given
that cpi readings would suggest the
exact opposite for example the most
recent cpi reading suggested an
inflation rate of 7.9 percent which is
the highest we've seen in four decades
also let's not forget that gas prices
are literally seven dollars a gallon in
some parts of the country but as jerome
has been preaching from the start this
slight increase in prices is just
transitory so gas prices should
stabilize at 6.50 cents any day now in
the meantime the commodities of our era
have been deflating faster than ever
before take apple for example people
often complain about how expensive apple
products have become as many of their
products cost well over a thousand
dollars they even sell a monitor stand
for one thousand dollars but the thing
that people forget to consider is that
apple has yet to raise prices on any of
these products despite rampant
dollars
inflation
2019 is equivalent to eleven hundred and
nine dollars today yet apple still only
charges a thousand dollars for the stand
this means that the pro stand has
dropped in price by roughly ten percent
now ten percent may not sound like much
but when you're talking about a 50 000
mac pro you're actually getting a 5 000
discount so as kathy wood was suggesting
the real fear is not inflation but
actually deflation but what does
deflation have to do with piracy
well during a deflation crisis cash is
king and unfortunately most millennials
have no cash this isn't all that
surprising given that the average
millennial would rather water their
plans than handle finances but it does
pose a serious problem
as baby boomers retire and cut back on
spending millennials are becoming the
workhorse of the economy but given that
most of them are broke we'll see less
capital flowing into dogecoin chiba inu
flokinu and the leading nfts so biden's
potential executive order is simply
attempting to curb this decline if
millennials no longer have to pay for
their 17 media entertainment
subscriptions every month they can
actually save a substantial amount of
money now it's not like they're gonna
save this for retirement but proponents
of this executive order are hoping that
they turn around and spend this money on
something more lucrative you see media
companies aren't the most lucrative
businesses disney for example hasn't
been able to crack a five percent margin
since the pandemic started meanwhile
starbucks has been holding strong at a
15 net margin which is three times
higher so if millennials spend more
money at starbucks instead of paying for
media which is probably where they'll
spend it corporate america can then turn
around and invest this extra money into
real assets such as stocks real estate
bonds and commodities like the mac pro
which will hopefully curb the impacts of
the deflation crisis
now that we've discussed the reasoning
behind this potential executive order
let's delve into the meat of the
legislation itself the first rumors of
such legislation surfaced from the
official tfes twitter account at 7 37
a.m
they tweeted quote watch out for buying
potential executive order 02496 piracy
may be legalized very soon
at first people didn't really know what
this meant but soon enough more and more
tweets started to surface tony stark for
example tweeted haha good thing i called
it with end game years ago shortly after
elon musk tweeted does this mean no more
iron man cameos meanwhile facebook
tweeted too bad the movie industry
didn't embrace the data collection model
all these cryptic tweets were still
quite confusing to put together but
eventually we saw a new wikipedia page
pop up that gave details into the
executive order the wikipedia page
describes a deflation threat that's
lumino over the united states and how
biden has little choice but to pass this
executive order if this executive order
were to pass piracy of all movies games
software and music would become
perfectly legal within the united states
on top of this all convicted pirates
will be cleared of all charges and
released from prison
now you may be wondering if no one is
paying for media then no production
company will want to produce any content
right well that's what everyone thought
at first including tony stark but
fortunately a powerful individual has
stepped up to the plate the executive
order outlines that any and all
production activities will be personally
funded by jerome's money printer jerome
figured that with the deflation getting
out of hand printing some extra cash
can't hurt
also production costs amongst even the
biggest production studios are peanuts
for jerome disney for example was
planning on spending just 33 billion
dollars on content in 2022 for jerome 33
billion dollars is just a day of
printing it if that so it doesn't look
like production studios will run into
any funding issues anytime soon
one thing to note though is that jerome
will only cover production costs and
that he won't be paying for profits so
these production studios don't have to
figure out how to monetize their viewers
to generate profits but moving forward
they'll never have to worry about
recouping production costs it's just a
matter of how much profits can they
generate
with such a game-changing piece of
legislation there's no doubt that we'll
see massive short-term and long-term
repercussions one of the first moves
we've seen production companies take is
initiating massive bidding wars for all
of the most popular piracy sites
now if this legislation passes netflix
disney hulu and all the other popular
streaming platforms will have download
links to all of their content on their
websites themselves but it seems like a
lot of people prefer to use the classic
piracy sites over these offerings hence
the bidding war kick-ass torrence for
example was recently acquired by an
undisclosed party for 32 billion dollars
meanwhile the pirate bay has apparently
received dozens of private offers with
the highest offer clocking in at over
100 billion dollars this is quite ironic
given that just a few hours ago
acquiring any one of these sites would
have been unthinkable given the insane
liabilities that each of them carries
also we should note that the executive
order hasn't even been passed yet so
these bidders are taking quite a risk by
prematurely acquiring these sites but i
guess they can afford it given the size
of the offer i think it's likely that
the offer is either from netflix or
disney but then again it could just as
easily be from google or facebook as
well like given that this is the perfect
opportunity to capitalize on the trend
towards piracy while art and ballen at
kick ass horn's founder quickly agreed
to sell kick-ass torrents the same
cannot be said about the pirate-based
founders for them running the pirate bay
is less about making money and more
about principle one of the pirate-based
co-founders frederick naij has literally
said that spending time in prison was
well worth it for the part b so it's not
surprising that they weren't enticed to
sell out to big tech not to mention that
they can likely make a lot more money if
they simply went public which seems to
be the plan godfritzfarthum tweeted mark
your calendars the pirate bay may have
an ipo on april 20th if this actually
does end up taking place the pirate bay
will evolve into being one of the
largest companies in the world basically
overnight also given that the three
co-founders currently own all the equity
in the company they'll each likely
become multi-deca billionaires so the
future is looking pretty bright for both
production companies and piracy sites
but only time will tell will become the
biggest part
in terms of the response to this
legislation that companies seem to be
all over the place adobe for example
tweeted
it's not like it makes a difference to
us anyway meanwhile disney has promised
a full-on press meeting to hash out
their plan and moving forward if they're
not able to acquire a large piracy site
like the pirate bay it's likely that
disney will ship to displaying ads and
collecting data similar to google and
facebook they'll probably also continue
to offer their movies and theater for
affiliate if people are still interested
as for the public most pirates don't
really care all that much the biggest
upside for them is that they no longer
have to pay for a vpn but then again if
disney and netflix start to collect data
through piracy sites it's probably best
to use a vpn anyway so this doesn't
really make a difference to most parts
meanwhile we've seen a lot of piracy
noobs navigating to rip off sites of the
pirate bay downloading various viruses
and falling for the stupidest of scams
it's probably best if these guys stick
to paying for their media until
companies come out with their own
download portals in terms of
country-wide responses russia has
perceived this as a challenge after all
they were the first world power to
losing restrictions on piracy so it
looks like biden is copying russia in an
effort to stay one step ahead of the us
it's speculated that putin will announce
that russia will not only allow for the
piracy of media but also the piracy of
intellectual property in other words all
patents and trademarks will become void
meaning that anyone can copy produce and
sell anything such a policy seems too
woke to be adopted by the us right now
but if the u.s enters a piracy war with
russia we may see similar policies
surfacing very soon but we'll just have
to wait and see do you guys support this
executive order comment that down below
also drop a like if you wish jerome's
money printer could subsidize your
operations and of course continue
checking out our international channels
to watch your videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more
questions illogically conspired but
until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you